wir haben hat schon die meldung
informiert was alles klappt und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video ja
heute will das wirklich lustiges an ich
hab selber noch nie gemacht ich wurde
praktisch überredet kann man so sagen
hier kennt sich nämlich immer damit sehr
gut aus und zwar habe ich dir denn alex
dabei was es nicht alles ohne dumme
geschichte angeblich nicht bei ihm handy
als alex abgespeichert was nicht stimmt
ich als felix mann
ich dachte noch nicht alles auch alle
also manchmal steht bei uns in den
kommentaren dass wir so manchmal ein
bisschen ähnlich aussehen hat das schon
ein paar mal gelesen und deswegen haben
wir uns das überlegt und machst ja ganz
gerne so mcdonald's ab und zu hab ein
paar auf dem gerade hochsaison 23 naja
also vielleicht kennt ihr das ja und wir
machen heute einen zusammen und zwar ein
ja und schaut mal mitgebracht haben
gekauft haben wir us truppen sollen
placement raushauen was eine kooperation
mit der firma ja auf jeden fall
kooperation gegen einen spaß seite war
einfach am günstigsten jetzt haben uns
hier eine mütze gekauft wird 92 und ein
rotes shirt guckt euch mal den schnitt
an also wenn der nicht heftig ist
freunde da können alle trassen marken
eintragen also es gibt schlimmeres so
ich habe auch sachen einpacken
ich habe aus notwehr sagt so von
günstigen klima also alles cool nix
gegen kik oder so freude
aber das günstigste die sachen sind
schon ganz gut sie mir doch mal an und
geben und als zwilling aus so also wir
ziehen die sachen an hat er gar schon
erklärt und dann fahren wir immer
abwechselnd wir haben so ein range rover
der ist ich bin mal gespannt ob ich
damit überhaupt nicht auf den champs de
mars meiner freunde
wir fahren immer abwechselnd rein
bestellen was und dann fährt der nächste
rein und sagt eigentlich hatte ich doch
gerade beispiel manchmal drei bestellten
cheeseburger dann fährt der nächste rein
sagt also mit den gleichen klamotten
hallo herr ich habe jetzt eigentlich
noch eine schicke gestell sie haben
einen cheeseburger geben so und so
machen wir das immer wieder wartet man
die frage ist jetzt wollen dass ich
einfach erst mal so machen und ohne ohne
die wir nicht tun werden aufgaben oder
mitteln direkt mit mehr aufgaben auf dem
sofa vorgeschlagen freuen denn man fährt
immer allein das heißt entweder alex
versteckt sich jeden oder ich und einer
davon immer wer vorne sitzt muss das
halt machen
darf die nicht nur aufgabe gehen das
heißt alex vorn und ich darf jetzt alle
wenn ich nur aufgabe ist aber platz naja
ich hab mich auf der seite müssen wir
nochmal ja auf jeden fall wenn wir das
so machen ist es kann zum beispiel vorne
alex dezenten und dann ergibt alex wäre
wenn ich die aufgabe ich muss ich machen
wenn ich nicht mache gibt auf jedem eine
heftige strafe die überlegen muss noch
schauen ob jemals wieder zu ende am ende
gibt's eine strahlende strafe ja wenn
man sich einmal auf jeden fall wenn du
bist nicht gesagt du machst es nicht auf
jeden her wenn du jetzt sagst spuckt da
rein so dass man natürlich nicht freunde
es müssen schon sachen sein ich okay
sind sowie auch alle machen können aber
ich denke man sich auf jeden fall lustig
was schätzt dich nicht vier runden
schaffen also ich will auch dabei ist
jemals einfahren zehnmal mehr heftig wo
also ich bin wirklich so einer
ich ziehe so was durch aber mir ist es
richtig unangenehm kann jetzt richtig
unangenehm
ich hab gar keine fremdschäm man nicht
nein ich ziehe einfach durch diese nicht
für voll überrascht der leute ist
eigentlich folge also ich einfach ein
geiles wieder raus zu hauen
willst du jetzt mach die haare macht die
harnwege rechte ja sonst haben wir
unterschiedliche absolut aus aber egal
dieses wird also ein bisschen freuen wir
uns mal die kamera wechseln wir wundern
uns gerade also sieht echt schon krass
ein bisschen echt so aus oder vom
gesicht her ja das hat ja auch in die
kommentare geschrieben sowohl bei den
videos und bei mir auch nicht vorne
allerdings gar keine ahnung davon
gefahren
du hast eine aufgabe legt gespannt was
da jetzt raus
hallo humor wie immer eigentlich ja
genau
bis gleich ich wusste jetzt nicht
aufgaben
was berger durchschneiden einer
mittlerweile weil du brauchst du
übrigens zwillingsbruder weil ich ihn
finden genau einmal einfach immer weiter
wir machen machen wir nicht aber ich
kann fragen gemacht mein freund kommt
hallo
können sie mir gefallen tun bitte können
sie eine hamburger anwalt der mitte
teilen ja genau das wäre super league
würde den superlangen weil die flüsse
beim horst detail dass er ganz cool
danke schön oh mein gott war längst ich
habe es irgendwie kommen
ich glaube ich bin der erste der erste
kunde jetzt mal wirklich sein hat
geklappt weil ich danke tschüss
natürlich angebot als ob irgendwas
falsch mit mir ist wie komme ich so an
aber ich glaube das ist ja nur
mitarbeiterin
nein ich kann nicht feststellen
der bürger ist gezahlt was sagst du dazu
die kraft gefunden hat wir wollen es
eigentlich einen cheeseburger haben der
geteilt das hast du mal händler bekommen
eine aufgabe ich muss mir schon eine
gute wenn ich die aufgabe überlegen
hallo ich war gerade schon mal da ich
hatte sie haben in hamburg gegeben
geteilt aber ich wollte eigentlich ein
cheeseburger war das falsch
okay du bist mein gott bist du lieber
richtig gut auf jeden fall ja weil du
meinst du jetzt einfach durch sie müssen
in den bürgerstuben sonst krieg vorbei
gar nicht schlimm
hast du ja alles gut alles gut bezahlten
schon alex wenn ich tue werde geld liegt
vorne noch 2 ausgleich das ist hier wer
nicht gehöre auf meine wenn ich zur
aufgabe wäre ist es thorsten links guten
papier
siehst du das das nimmst du einfach
machst dir sechs scheiben davon ab von
den c war und macht sie das hier an den
links uns hier als der gast gesagt
safety first ich muss mich jetzt erstmal
nicht folglich an
ok also kurz bevor sie den burger gibt
machst du das okay let's go alex
[Musik]
das ist noch das ist heute sicher dass
ich nicht mehr zueinander
ok ich kann mich angeguckt ich habe
keine ahnung ich gar nicht für mich
interessiert mich gerade in der
vielleicht ich glaube dir das geld also
sie hat auf jeden fall nicht gereicht
ich selbst fahre ich auf jeden fall
nicht gefällt dass wir zwei
unterschiedliche menschen so okay das
ist schon mal gut dass wir auch die
intention beim zügige sprengt aber ich
finde ich einfach weiter durch ich sagen
jetzt also ich glaube die machen einfach
ihre arbeit und das könnte auch gut sein
wird das gute ist die visa muss einfach
nur dran halten das geht schnell gut
aber nicht so freuen uns noch ein
bisschen action rein zu bekommen muss
ich jetzt natürlich ein bisschen frecher
sein aber ist nicht so schlimm dass er
manchmal ein bisschen frech aber wie
gesagt ich entschuldige mich am ende
also du bist jetzt ein bisschen bis ein
bisschen ein bisschen hofft reval jetzt
freunde und dann wirst du einfach
gemacht
ich bin einfach der zunächst und du bist
so der liebe okay die gute frau wurde
sehr gut aber jetzt mal kurz einmal
beschweren ich war schon das dritte mal
jetzt ich bin das dritte mal jetzt hier
und weil die ganzen schicken im ersten
hamburger bekommen schließlich wollte
man schicken bürger nicht einmal gesagt
ich hab nur gesagt ich möchte ja genau
ich möchte meinen schicken bürgern
durchgeschnitten haben
[Musik]
ich habe ja ich glaube ja dann mache ich
jetzt halten schicken bürger war ich das
ist das ist wirklich doof gerade jetzt
wirklich jetzt ja und kann ihre kollegin
sich bei mir entschuldigen weil das
sieht jetzt auch noch wäre ich habe
richtig durchgezogen
jetzt geht weiter was steckt nicht
alltägliche aufgabe jetzt gleich das du
richtig bekannt service
das ist aber nur ein zweitwagen und das
ok im nächsten musste was machen das ist
schon mal wenn ich die aufgabe du musst
gleich eine in story machen irgendwann
und zwar was machen überlegt ich bin
euch doch nicht so gut drauf ich bin das
nicht was uns trennt sondern auf das was
uns da bin ich dann in instagram als mal
[Musik]
ich verstehe nicht was die meine
instagram ich weiß nicht was ihr problem
ist ja aber sie müssen doch wissen
gucken sie schauen sie mal dienstag wenn
ich muss eben einiges daraus machen habe
ich den bürgern wieder raus sagt okay
für mich persönlich finde ich will mich
so freunde was geht euer beliebtester
tik tok ist wieder am start ich gehe es
gab eine brücke ein bisschen belästigt
ich weiß auch nicht warum aber auf jeden
fall bezahlt erstmal deutsche richtige
abfahrt wir wurden erkannt bzw
wo der kampf schon mal war das war vor
einem halben jahr das kann jetzt gar
nicht seine leute ich muss jetzt hier
ein bevor ihr die cops rufen alex
funktioniert hältst du mit dem kauf wir
müssen ja weil ich mich jetzt erst mal
abstand entschuldigung von uns die
polizei rufen
das kennzeichen aufgeschrieben gar nicht
gerade aber erklärt dass eben doch mal
wir müssen jetzt eben rein kurz und dann
machen wir das denn vom aller macs hier
ist war mcdonald's und da machen wir
einfach weiter ok richtig gelassen ich
weiß auch nicht was mit ihr los dann hat
erst mal fünf minuten gedauert bis sich
rauch kam und wir dachten ja die ist
jetzt so angepisst die rutschpartie oder
die zeile dass der polizei keine ahnung
und sie sagt dann hat er gesagt sorry
ich muss so besser sein dann tut uns
leid so war er war schon mal hier und
diese ja ich kann auch böse sein okay
und ebenso wollte in wasser und sie hat
jetzt ein wasser gestellt und er sagte
ich möchte ich es haben dann hast du
nichts genommen ja ich dachte ich wieder
etwas essen würden sofort gewinnen
los geht es von den weiter geht jetzt
alles wieder am steuer
und jetzt mal ein dünnes und wir machen
es einfach genauso weiterhin nicht nur
eine aufgabe wenn ich du wäre gut heißt
du meine wiese gehört hab ich nicht
ja
[Musik]
es wurden wir irgendwie direkt schon
wieder erkannt hier
da ist die überregional bekannt für
seine mcdonnell springs weit aber nicht
noch im gefängnis was machst du denn
haben wir uns jetzt hier raus
wie haben sie das gesehen ich kann mir
auch mein leben nicht klar leute ich bin
nur ausgegangen jetzt hier habe den
fahrerwechsel gemacht wollte jetzt
einsteigen stehen drei mitarbeiter haben
wir gesehen ja ja das war die
filialleiterin sie macht schon so ich
sagte ich soll ihn komme ich gehe hier
brauchen wir haben hat schon die meldung
ganz dortmund sind informiert was alles
oder wir fahren jetzt einfach schön
wahrscheinlich wollen wir doch cologna
macdonald schief gelaufen habe schon
gesagt du bist hier überregional bekannt
aber wie haben sie uns den gesehen
wahrscheinlich wieder faxen haben direkt
gemeldet ja hier das ist der nächste mac
ist die kommen jetzt wahrscheinlich zu
euch bestimmt angerufen weißt du ja wie
gesagt dass wir um bildung bekommen die
haben wir uns denn hier gesehen das ist
die sache so leute video ist fertig
geschnitten irgendwie erst mal
aufgefallen ich habe kein anderer
gemacht oder wie das war mir auch sehr
wichtig und es hat auch echt spaß
gemacht die haben so wichtig seien sehr
freundlich auf
das sieht schon eine größere effekt auf
jeden fall in zweiter partien gibt es
bei felix auf dem kanal mich euch ganz
meiner wie die beschreibung von link da
gibts noch ein paar weitere lustige
szenen also es lohnt sich auf jeden fall
abzuchecken
mit felix auch auf jeden fall würde mich
sehr freuen wir machen glaube ich in
zukunft öfter mal was steht uns nicht
gut aber sonst bin ich sagen dass mit
dem video
für mich geht es jetzt nach norwegen
gespannt und